I think the last two days
have been very challenging for me
because after winning against Rafa,
I almost felt
like the tournament was done
because most of the times
when we meet,
it's in the finals of events.
This time, it was in the semi-final
and it was a great battle
lasting over four hours.
I needed to regroup.
I needed to recharge my batteries
and try to come out on the court
against Tsitsipas,
who was in form,
and perform my best.
It wasn't easy at all...
considering what I've been through
in the semi-finals.
It took a lot out of me emotionally,
physically and mentally as well.
After a bit of a slower start
for me,
I found my groove,
I found my rhythm
and adjusted to the conditions that
were different from the semi-finals.
And after a very good start
in the third set,
there was no looking back.
I found my game
and I managed
to start to read his game
and finish off the match
in the best possible style.
Coming back from two sets down,
I don't think I've ever done that
in the finals of a slam.
So, it makes this win extra special.
Well, Paris has been
a very particular place for me
in my career
because I've tried so many times
to win Roland-Garros
and it was the only Grand Slam
that I never won
and that I was missing until 2016.
I can recall the feelings
that I had on the court
when I won that match in 2016.
It was, I think,
most of all, a huge relief
because there was
so much expectations and pressure
being built from myself
and then, of course,
from everyone else around me,
that I had to win it,
after losing two or three finals.
And ever since then...
I was always
kind of coming back to Paris
hoping that I could do it again,
at least before I ended my career.
It's not like my end
is anywhere near.
I'm not thinking about it,
but I just felt like
winning Roland-Garros for me
was probably the biggest task
of any other Slam,
because of Rafa
and just because of the surface,
and I think the game itself.
So, to win it again at this age
and at this stage of my career
is something very remarkable.
I'm very grateful and very thrilled
with that achievement.